foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people
build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships number one best-selling
author and host of the Dr John deloney
shows Dr John baloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
thank you for joining us America we
appreciate you hanging out the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five thank you for jumping
in we appreciate you I'm going to start
off this hour with Michael he is in
Roanoke Virginia hi Michael welcome to
the Ramsay show hey Dave how are you
guys great man what's up
hey um so kind of get straight to it
um so me and my fiance have been having
some discussions about a car she was
gifted when she graduated
um her stepmother had talked to her dad
into putting a lien on the car for about
ten thousand dollars
and it's been about five years now and
we're starting to run into some problems
with the car
um and since those uh in the last two
years her dad and stepmom have moved and
have not given any addresses haven't
made any contact haven't got any
responses to texts or calls
um so don't really know what to do as
far with the car uh I would say it's
probably getting into the point where
it's Spartan starting to get under that
ten thousand as value
um so we're trying to think of
if it's worth just running it till the
wheels fall off and dropping off in
their driveway if I can find it or
really what to do
so why the disconnect
why these people took off and nobody
knows where they are
um honestly I think it's you know she
had a really good relationship with her
her dad
and she's got two or three other
brothers and sisters that also did and
then when this new lady came in about
say four years ago five years ago she's
kind of been more controlling his uh he
works with her now after he was retired
um it's kind of like if when she was on
the phone with him before they had to be
on speakerphone she was in the
background always talking if you know if
he could never have one-on-one time with
his kids practically
so it's been kind of a mess it's hurt
her a lot because they were very close
when she was living with them and then
after college and things but it was kind
of just disappear off the face of the
Earth
um just a as a point of clarification
he could have talked to his kids but he
chose not to
yeah and that is focusing all this
energy on we hate her hey stepmom she's
the worst this lady this lady this lady
that's misdirected grief the grief is
Dad has chosen a different life that
doesn't include us
and that hurts
like the like the pit of Hell
and we got to deal with it from that we
got to deal with that right that does it
doesn't help your your car situation but
that's where the grief has to start
and when Dad moves away and doesn't even
tell you where he is
um that's a very clear behavior is a
language that's a very clear statement I
don't want you in my life and that hurts
man
yeah absolutely she's been very her butt
and it's kind of caught her off guard I
think I believe too sure
that should catch everybody off guard
it's not how it should be yeah
um you can only control what you know
where you can control you can't control
what he does but okay let me give you
some husband advice I'll turn over to
Dave don't ever say that to her okay
just hold her hand and say this hurts
and I'm sorry
all right okay there you go and it's her
dad's fault not our Stepmother's fault
yeah he chose
he chose you can't blame the other
person talked him into it he got talked
into it he chose he made a conscious
choice now
um
I assume this is in the state of
Virginia
yes okay different states handle
Carlene's different ways in our state
the lean has to be actually written on
the car title do you guys hold a
physical title that has a name written
on it yes sir okay all right
um
well what I would do is contact an
attorney
and see it's probably I'll give you a
guess this is going to cost you a
thousand bucks
but it's less than ten thousand bucks
um and I would uh see if there's not
some sort of motion to be filed before
the court that uh removes this lien
that just says this lien was placed by a
father just to control the car after he
gave it as a gift he's disappeared we
can't find him to get the lien release
there was never any Financial transfer
it was a control mechanism and we're
asking for the judge to remove the lien
clean the title
okay and I think I'm almost positive
there'll be some sort of legal motion
that can be done and hopefully it's a a
small claims court thing since it's ten
thousand dollars okay and it's not it's
not a super expensive thing but you know
I would think you're going to spend a
thousand dollars to do that uh your only
other option is
um if you want to save the thousand
dollars is go find this guy
and show up okay and show up because
y'all kind of know where he is she's
just hurt but he works for her she has a
business you know what that is you can
find that business you can find this
duper and just show up and go hey duber
you need to release this
you already hurt your daughter you've
crushed her uh with your abandonment and
you need to sign this and I'm her
husband here telling you you need to
sign this now and if you don't I'm gonna
drag your horrible butt into court and
embarrass you
so I'm gonna act as the angry husband if
I'm you
okay don't shoot anybody that's not what
I said okay Dave did you hear this guy
he was like all right
I can do this but you don't you don't
need to involve her and this is not
about trying to repair their
relationship and this is not you don't
need to take her this is business now
and this has not got nothing to do with
the uh stepmother you need a signature
from a doofus this should have been a
better dad that's all you need
save a thousand bucks I'm gonna go drive
over there because dude you can find him
I promise you I can I can tell by the
way the story went down y'all actually
know you just haven't chased them I uh
often tell them because you didn't want
to find them there's a moment when you
stop being my father-in-law and you
start being the man who keeps making my
wife cry yeah and when you switch that
switch when that switch flips now we're
having a different conversation Dave
help me here I'm I'm ignorant what does
that mean that you can just put a lien
on something like that well I mean
if you have a car title you can ride on
there a lean just take your car title
flip it over on the back in Most states
there's a place for the lien holder and
that's where the bank writes a lien on
there and then the bank typically if you
do it with a bank right or a car company
that has a car payments they'll hold the
title they keep the title physically but
in this case Michael has the physical
title it just has written on it
and you can't take it down and transfer
it because it has written on it'll lean
and that lien has to be released until
ten thousand dollars what does that mean
well no I mean it's just he just made up
a number and put it on there the dad did
to control the car he wanted to make
sure the car didn't get sold without his
permission
[Music]
that's what he was doing okay and there
was no actual transfer of cash here he
didn't loan them ten thousand dollars he
gave her a car and then the stepmother
goes ah she just gonna go sell it and
run off with some boy and he goes okay
I'll just put a lien on it put a leash
and a dog collar and his daughter and
said you tell me thank you for that
exactly wow what a jury and then took
off to the mountains and we're gonna go
find Boy Child this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
John it's been about a year since own
your past change your future hit the
shelves that's right since it was
published I got tons of calls from
people asking me for private sessions
and can we just talk for an hour or two
and obviously I can't meet one-on-one
with every single person it's not
possible but that's why I wrote own your
past danger future think of us sitting
across from one another having a
conversation the book offers practical
advice and encouragement on topics like
relationship overcoming past hurts and
healing from traumas and as you read
through each section I'll show you how
to how to learn from what happened in
your past so you can go create this new
life and listen for the first time ever
we're including it in the 10 sale but
you gotta hurry the sale ends in one
week get own your pass change your
future today or any of the questions for
humans conversation cards Dave I just
got a note from the guys over in the
store good grief those questions for
human questions for human guards so like
crazy
ramseysolutions.com everything's 10
bucks so go for it love it check it all
out Melanie is in Los Angeles hi Melanie
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um I've recently entered baby step four
and I was curious what the most
effective way to save the 15 for
retirement is when you have irregular
independent contractor income
um I imagine the simplest way is 15
divided by the 12 months but some months
I make three thousand dollars some
months I make eight thousand dollars and
after my four walls and saving for taxes
I don't always have that left
uh
um
and how are you you're your independent
contractor so you're funding this as uh
just Roth IRAs right
correct yes okay
you know you could just set the money
aside each month and then do it once a
year into the investment
okay and just make sure and then if
you're if you're short one month you
make it up another month right
okay yeah
yeah I was curious if there was like a
secret
no there's no there's no secret it's
just uh you know if you've if you have
to drop into your food budget because
you had an automatic draft at 15 of your
income right then that's not cool
yeah that's not helpful yeah and you're
you're uh you know your your income is
volatile enough that you could have that
so um yeah you run it on the average and
then just say on average each month I
need to do this if I have a three
thousand dollar a month I can't do it so
I got to make it up the other month when
I have an 8 000 a month
okay and by the end the end of year it's
just about making sure that there's 15
of whatever that ends up yeah yeah the
problem with that is just the uh
discipline that it requires the
attention to detail that it requires
yeah and uh and so that you just gotta
guard against uh getting sloppy
but I don't try to set up systems that
require me to do details I set up
systems that are Auto
and this is not Auto so the only way I
know how to do this is manually and what
you're talking about yeah what you're
talking about but if you just you know
but make sure that you set yourself up
on a plan that that if you're not a
detailed person and you've got something
that's driving you to keep the system in
place
I have to wonder if some of the
challenges with the irregular income
aren't the same challenges that would
make this hard
right if you are a strong have strong
attention to detail when you're getting
started and you are strong focused on
your marketing on your business
the irregularity might not be there
might not be there yeah that's a
possibility yeah possibility so you know
if you're doing uh let's say you're an
industry that is not known for detail
like if you're an accountant or an
engineer you'd be known for detail if
you were a graphic artist you might not
be known for detail right and so if
that's what's going on because my wife
would be much better at putting money
aside in the designated shoe you would
and writing a check December 15th for a
Year's worth yeah should definitely be
better I'm going to mail in some
Skittles wrappers and hope that they
deposit your uh keep your attention span
off of the gummy bears yeah that would
be true all right Nick is in Grand
Rapids Michigan hi Nick welcome to the
Ramsay show hi I thank you for taking my
call sure um my question is what to do
with uh unexpected income whether to put
it on our mortgage or uh use it for a
startup bathroom remodel
uh is that the baby step you're in
uh yeah
okay so you're putting 15 of your income
away for retirement
yes sir have you got children
one maybe yep okay and are you
addressing their uh College in baby step
five
yep okay so you don't need it for either
one of four or five you're down to six
or a bathroom
either one is fine how much money are we
talking about
I mean not a ton my wife uh is currently
not working because she stayed at home
for the first six months of our son's
life and um it's just 700 a month for
babysitting
foreign
I would just put that in your budget and
then decide what you want to do with it
and but then it takes you back to
because baby steps four five and six is
when you can do some things like upgrade
a bathroom or put it on the mortgage and
either one is fine you guys just need to
be in agreement about what the budget
looks like because if a hundred percent
of the time you get extra money you
never throw it at the mortgage you
always upgrade something you're never
going to pay off the mortgage early if a
hundred percent of the time you throw it
at the mortgage early and you don't do
any upgrades or any increases of quality
of life and lifestyle you're that's not
sustainable emotionally you're going to
burn up
so I you know you've got to just find
that balance that ebb and flow and that
the tide goes in the tide goes out thing
to where you get some of each going on
but 700 bucks is not building a bathroom
so it's you know 10 months from now
you'd have seven thousand dollars and
you might talk about doing some kind of
bathrooms I think I saw a stat the other
day that the average bathroom remodel is
eight million dollars good gosh I've
told you at least a thousand times not
to exaggerate good grief I had someone
come look at our house and they're like
yeah we can knock this out here's kind
of the
this it's going to be 14 million dollars
yeah they charged you a million just to
come do that just to give you the
estimate yeah I don't know what they put
under the subfloors and bathrooms but
good gold that's where you store your
gold yeah open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us Johnny is in
Connecticut hi Johnny welcome to the
Ramsey Show
ing me sure what's up
uh so I just bought a house a year ago
and I currently have about like 45 000
sitting in an account with a money
manager and I've had my money with him
for about three years now and I'm still
sitting at my original investment so I'm
wondering how great it's doing in there
and if it'd be better to just put that
towards my mortgage
I always put 100 of non-retirement
savings above the emergency fund towards
the mortgage
right so you think that it would be
better off I always show the mortgage I
always put 100 of non-retirement savings
above the emergency fund toward the
mortgage until the mortgage is paid off
because otherwise let's say you had that
invested in mutual funds as an example
okay all right and you didn't reduce
your mortgage balance sheet wise it's as
if you borrowed on your house to invest
in mutual funds
and you wouldn't do that
[Music]
so pay down the mortgage
okay yeah because I do plan on selling
the house in about a year and a half so
I figured it'd be better off doing that
and then I'm actually putting more
principles down on my house every month
then
let's get your house paid off I mean
whether it's this one or the next one
when you sell your house if you paid
down the mortgage they give you a check
it's called Equity paying down the
mortgage is not an expenditure that goes
that has lost money it's laying there
you're banking it in dirt and bricks and
mortar and also Dave isn't there a
chance that over the last three years
with the up and down on the volatility
that you could look up and being even
would be a pretty good place to be yeah
I don't think your guys doing a bad job
if he was doing a great job if he made
20 on your money I would still tell you
pay down your house because all the data
points we have that says the shortest
distance between where you are and your
first one to five million dollars of net
worth is getting your stinking house
paid off
and the and loading 15 to 20 of your
income into your retirement not playing
footsie with some brokerage account
that's not there I mean it's not there
there's no data that says that Financial
footsie that's it I mean you can find
that on Tic Tac but you can't find that
with real millionaires this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back there why
they're watching guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thanks
for joining us today's question is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services spring is here and it's
time to handle those projects that have
been on pause neighborly's got top
quality home service providers like Mr
Handyman Glass Doctor Precision garage
door service and shelf Genie so find the
local help you need at neighborly.com
today today's question comes from
Catherine in Florida she writes I'm a
long time follower of your baby step
program and I enjoy catching up on your
radio show on YouTube that sentence did
not exist a few years ago
my question is about how to deal with
family members opinions on living below
your means driving an older car having
older Electronics a small apartment Etc
I lived in a studio apartment while I
was in college after graduation I landed
a great job working at an investment
advisory firm and moved into a
two-bedroom apartment with a roommate we
both work remotely and use the second
bedroom as an office recently my
roommate's Aunt stopped by to see the
new apartment and commented that it was
small I didn't say anything to her but
inside I felt terrible a two-bedroom
apartment was an upgrade for me in terms
of space and with the increase in my
income and shared expenses I was
spending less money than I was when I
was a student
I know we can't control what others say
and they are definitely entitled to
their opinions I also don't want to
imply that their aunt is judgmental well
she is I just want to know how I can
control that inner voice that felt
embarrassed when someone didn't
understand why I live the way that I do
oh that's a great question
um I find Dave when I
have not spent some time making sure my
values are anchored into an identity
other people can throw I can I can try
things like a new workout like a new
diet plan or something and somebody will
just casually dismiss it
and all it will affect me but when I
have made a choice I'm a guy who
fill in the blank takes my kid to Waffle
House Waffle House is probably not the
healthiest choice for us but that's
where we go and I love it and I won't
miss it
and so I don't it doesn't even doesn't
even enter my mind when somebody makes a
comment about oh that's not healthy like
because I'm so anchored into that as a
thing or someone dismisses my faith out
of hand like I didn't I don't lose a
second of sleep over that because it's
it's an anchor point to me I've
connected my values with my identity
it it feels like if you're trying
something on
it's a recipe for somebody can speak
into it
yeah
um
but I'm just I'm kind of I'm kind of
thinking off top my head here so
pushback if that doesn't sound right
godliness with contentment
is a great game
and so if you are content
and this is your decision
you have peace
sitting in the decision and that's an
identity that's a it's a much less nerdy
way to say that I mean I just you're
sitting in your identity yeah and then
you know you're okay if you know the
aunt wants to get a bigger apartment
it's that's her choice but this is what
I wanted and
you know you think um
you know I have a black pickup truck you
think black pickup trucks are ugly well
that's okay I'm really comfortable I
picked that truck I like it and so
you know I don't really
give a rip the verbiage for me changed
back when um and you and I've talked
about this quite a bit
when I with the phrase you don't get a
vote yeah and so really sitting down and
deciding being intentional in my life
who are the people who do get a vote
yeah my wife a couple of clothes like
it's a very very small list
when it comes to I want to challenge
your value yeah I think it comes down to
like you said how anchored are you in
this because it's it's a great
discussion that's why we're having it
but the uh
uh uh
if you're anchored in it and you really
believe it then you wouldn't be
embarrassed yeah somebody came by and
goes uh you know this guy is green right
you're actually right
when they bring something up
and you're not that anchored in it then
it would throw you off absolutely it's
like I mean do you live in a dump you
know I mean if you do maybe she's
telling you you need to upgrade you know
I mean that that's a that may be what's
going on but if you're just completely
comfortable with that
um
and uh
yeah I I think that I think you're
exactly right it's how far you're
anchored into it I mean I got into this
thing this morning I was at a uh another
event and I was one of the speakers and
I ended up back in the green room with a
bunch of these guys that were
intellectuals which is always fun for me
because I'm a wiener in a steakhouse and
um so this this guy is throwing out you
know this verbiage and he's like yes but
what about arbitraging and if you pay
off your two and a half percent mortgage
and all this and I finally looked at him
I said dude
I think you need to keep your mortgage
but you asked me
what I thought
and I own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate debt free
and when covet hit
I wasn't worried about payments so
that's how I live if you don't want to
do it it's okay
but you know even though you're a
bazillion times smarter than me
I got more real estate than you do
I mean you know and it's all paid for so
the real question is can you kick my you
know it's just you know I mean it's kind
of that you know
why are we are why you know okay I get
it but did you really think you were
going to have a discussion with Dave
Ramsey in the green room and talk him
out of into going into that and you were
going to sit back and go is there
anything I've never thought of it no way
I mean not intellectually that you
finally I found someone who was smart
enough that got me on this no way after
30 years no you're kidding you know and
I'm just like
oh I mean whatever you want to do dude
it's okay I'm not mad at you I love you
you can go you can go get in debt if you
want but as for me and my house we're
pretty anchored in this one pretty much
an identity thing yes I would go back to
Catherine and say why are you why are
you choosing this life yeah well I want
to live alone my means and okay great
then other people don't get a vote
everything that she said was joyful
absolutely until the aunt showed up that
didn't get a vote yeah and so she didn't
get a vote that's all it is it's um and
that's something you practice that's
that's easier said than done it is and
the other thing is this it's a
perspective thing
um it goes with contempt so the thing I
always remember is this I have the
inordinate benefit of having gone
completely broke and once you've gone
completely broke you really don't care
what other people think
because you figure out most of them
aren't going to be around anyway it's
like watching a fighter that's been
knocked out they're a little Wilder the
next time because they oh that's what
happens oh that's how it works I didn't
die from it now I can be a little bit
more religious I'm gonna lean in here
and you know I love folk and I I want
you to win and I want to help you but
um I'm not really taking a poll
you know before I make a decision on
stuff I'm not I'm just I lost what the
Bible calls fear of man I just don't
I don't need affirmation to make good
quality value-based decisions I make
those decisions regardless and if I get
some affirmation that's wonderful I'm
like anybody else I like it but I don't
have to have that to do anything and and
honestly when some of you get pissed off
it kind of inspires me so
um you know I it causes me to go to
double down you know so
um and because I've found that most of
you are that wrong and so that's why we
do this show for 30 years is to help you
you know and so yeah I think there's a
lot of that going on in the contentment
thing is contentment is do I have peace
am I anchored in this with a deep a part
of my identity
um and how much affirmation do I need to
support my values based decisions and
the less of that you need the better
financial decisions you're going to make
all day every day because most people
are broke and if your broke friends are
making fun of yourself financial plan
you are right on track well and the
better parenting decisions you'll make I
don't want my kid to be the only kid
with three-year-old without their own
iPad be the only one I don't want my kid
to be the only you're gonna make better
parenting better marriage decisions you
make every every decision will be better
when you identify who gets a vote and
who doesn't and when you identify that
identity and what it's anchored into man
yeah my kids weren't homeschooled but I
saw this thing the other day that I
thought was in the current world we live
in was pretty funny the guy's like God
get the dump button ready really you
ready one guy's saying to the other he
goes you know your children are not
going to be socialized and not going to
be like all the other children if you
homeschool them and the guy goes yep
you are correct
[Laughter]
sir yeah
um yeah that'd be you know
yeah I don't want to be cray-cray it's a
good thing yeah
it's tough out there man man yeah some
of y'all people have lost it I'm just
saying this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Travis is with us in Grand
Rapids Michigan hi Travis welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Mr Ramsey Dr John deloney it's a
pleasure to speak to you both today you
too what's up
um so I am my question is how do you get
out of debt with my current salary as a
truck driver projected to make 80 000
this year
okay
how much is your debt um
sick total debt is 67 000
um 40 000 is student loan debt and then
I have 11
000 balance on a car and the rest is
credit cards okay you're single I've
been trying to make a
um I am dating currently living with
um my partner and
so that's kind of tricky because when I
moved in with her I was over the road
and now I'm a local driver
um so I I pay her to help her with the
mortgage
um
but we're not married yet planning on
engagement soon so
okay so you are paying part of your
roommates
payment as rent
essentially yes yeah and your rent is
how much
uh 500 a month okay all right so you
make eighty thousand dollars a year and
you have a 500 a month rental
okay yep so what's wrong with getting on
a tight tight tight tight tight tight
tight tight budget and beginning to pay
these debts down
in this budget
yeah and I've been trying to see that
for myself like I have in my notes all
my bills and credit cards
um how much each monthly payment the sum
of them is for the minimum balance I've
been following uh listening to you guys
over the last couple months for the baby
sets yeah but I just can't seem to get
ahead of you don't you haven't done it
so what is your take-home pay
um about 1200 a week okay you get paid
once a week
correct okay you sit down and you look
at June
how many times are you going to get a
paycheck let's pretend it's four okay
that would give you four thousand eight
hundred dollars to work with
minus 500 for rent
minus food correct minus some car gas
minus the minimum payments on all of
these bills and everything else goes
towards the stupid credit card until
it's gone
and you cut up the credit card
two of them up since I've started
listening to you I've paid I still feel
like you drove right past all the room
that should be in this budget forty
eight hundred dollars minus 500 minus
food that's a buttload of money left
over
yeah it's about thirty six hundred
dollars or thirty seven hundred dollars
yeah how much is the balance on the
credit card
um I have three of them left
um
once
2150 600 and 700. okay you should pay
the 600 and 700 off this month and
probably the 2150. yep so you're you're
done with credit cards in two months one
month oh one month let's do it
okay but you're not going out to eat
and you're not going on vacation
and you're not going drinking with your
buddies
you got no life you're getting ready to
clean up your dad gum mess because you
want to get married
yes and it's time to clean up your mess
so what I'm teaching you is what's
called a zero based budget your income
each month unique to that month minus
every dollar gets an assignment every
dollar has a mission every dollar has a
name beside it before the month begins
before June gets here next week you need
to have figured out what your income for
June is and assign every one of those
dollars first to Necessities food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities so rent
car payment
car gas
food okay that's it and then everything
else dude we're going at this at these
credit cards like they're the freaking
enemy because they are
yeah if you had 4 800 minus 500 and you
had twenty six hundred dollars makes you
debt free or I'm sorry 20 uh 3 200 makes
you debt free you're debt free of your
credit cards in one month you really
should be
right
that's how you do it absolutely that's
how you do it right there and jump
online and pick up their or hang on
we'll give you uh the every dollar app
and uh we'll get you tied into the uh
Advanced version of the every dollar app
which connects to your bank and helps
you run your budget it's the world's
best budgeting app and it'll help you
but it's giving every dollar a name
that's the point when you get very
detailed very nuanced and very careful
with your planning each and every single
month and you squeeze every one of these
dollars until Benjamin Franklin is
squealing then you are ready to go and
that's what we're doing and we're not
we're not spending money on anything
because we're trying to clean this mess
up so realistically you've got 50 uh uh
two
fifty five thousand dollars in debt you
make eighty thousand but you got almost
no expenses you probably could be 100
debt free in a year
pretty close a year and for everybody
listening I want don't don't blow by
this because it's easy to look at him
and be like man that guy
you can't out earn your your
unintentionality your lack of
intentionality he's making eighty
something thousand dollars a year and he
can't figure out where it's going where
how to pay off a two thousand dollar
credit card can't figure it out and and
it's not because he's dumb it's because
it's just chaos there's too many spin in
place everywhere yep and that's what a
budget does it's all it's all
spun up in your brain and then The Ether
and everything else and so giving every
dollar an assignment every time you do
this people if those of you that haven't
done it you need to sit down and do it
tonight June's coming next week and you
sit down and do your dad gone budget
maybe for the first time in your life
put your income for the month at the top
of the page and then give every dollar
an assignment I will promise you two
things will happen number one thing will
happen is that you will feel like you
got a raise because you will go where is
all this freaking money going
it's going to blow your mind how much
you waste
and the second thing that's going to
happen is you're going to get a sense of
Peace instead of a sense of anxiety even
though you've actually done nothing with
money yet now you've actually executed a
plan that says if I take these 17 steps
I'm going to be free
and as soon as you see the steps in
front of you then you realize they're
doable your anxiety goes down your uh
stress level goes down your peace level
goes up and you kind of just slick your
hair back and go okay let's get about
the business of doing this let's go game
on and people lean into it and it
changes everything Timothy is in Chicago
hi Timothy welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you sir it's a pleasure to be on
your show today honored to have you
what's up
we my wife and I are wondering if we
should use a portion of our emergency
fund to pay our mortgage off how much is
in your emergency fund
currently we are at 46.5 okay and we owe
30 all intents and purposes 34.
okay and you don't have any other money
you have to put into this equation so
you would drain your 46.5 by 34.
yes sir
what's your household income
uh base salaries we're looking at 100 no
no I didn't ask ask what your household
income is
between my mine and my life we're
looking at 100 like I said 136. okay
okay good good yeah all right and uh so
here's the thing
paying off a house is a really good
thing and we really tell everybody to do
it it's not an emergency so if you go
below three to six months if you go
below three months
of expenses in order to do this you cut
too deep and it kind of feels like you
are
okay
what do you think what's what's three
what's three months of expenses
three months of expenses were I believe
we're looking at 18 19 000. all right
let's call it 20 which means you have
26.5 to throw at your 34.
okay did I get that right
yes sir okay and then in the next by
Christmas you just cash flow the rest of
it knock it out
okay uh now my wife will be getting
bonuses throughout the next several
months which will be paying down the
mortgage further yeah given that
happening yeah we're looking at August
okay done now a question oh go ahead I'm
sorry then do it done absolutely go that
route that's what I would do yeah that's
the whole idea so by Christmas we're
rebuilding the emergency fund maybe from
three months up to six months which you
don't need more than 40. let's play
August I mean that's if he pays this
thing off in August with some bonuses
well then they got to rebuild it right
from 20 up to 40. oh by Christmas no
more than 40 in your emergency fund you
don't need 46 in your emergency fund if
20 represents three months 40 represents
six months six months is enough then
move on to your other steps this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
John deloney if you
if you're on your money Journey we have
a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Dr John baloney
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Kim is going to start off this
particular hour
she's in San Francisco hi Kim how are
you
great thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um I need you to give me some advice on
how to get my foster child to make
better financial decisions
what's going on
um he was given a scholarship
um and on April 14th he had about
2 600 dollars that we put in a college
um savings account or I guess it's a
checking savings account
um I had to leave town for a little bit
and then he figured out he didn't have
the card but he figured out how to use
the pay on your phone
um app and I just saw it Vanishing
before my eyes and it's down to about a
thousand dollars now since April 14th
and I've had multiple conversations with
him about budgeting and
oh but I think he's just impulsive due
to his history
um yeah this how old is he
was 17 and a half how long has you been
with you
since April
um
well you don't really get to play the
mom card
when you've been with them since April
all right
um in other words it's tougher uh this
is with a 17 year old especially uh I
would think you're in the persuasion
business
foreign
who has uh
presumably been in several different
houses over his life
have a sense of foundation and a sense
of vision for his life
that makes him think longer than Friday
and plan longer than Friday which is
what you're trying to get him to do and
so I think it's more about having a
vision for your life
which you had for him more than he had
for him what's he spending this money on
um
a lot of food
um he bought a model the other day
um just
kind of silly things and he even came in
a few days ago and said that he looked
back on you know he can see everything
as well in the bank account and said you
know I kind of wish I hadn't bought all
that stupid stuff as the exact words
that he used and then I was able to have
a conversation with him but he just
still can't help himself in the moment
do you have the ability to restrict
access to these funds
I'm not I'm not sure
um I was thinking about myself but I was
hoping that
you know maybe having a conversation
with him well there's another one it's a
common a common trajectory for kids who
are aging out of the foster care system
is a almost obsessive need for autonomy
because they've never had it
and so suddenly this kid who's just
inches away from being 18 has an account
with a couple of thousand dollars in it
I'm not gonna be great I I completely
understand where his sweet brain is
going which is I can finally eat where I
want to eat I can finally buy a thing
that I want to buy
and Dave is right it's
I'm asking if you can restrict it but
that's not something you do just behind
his back that might be a conversation
you'll have sitting down together with
him I think I would sit down with him
and say listen
um we love you and we're worried about
you would you like us to put the money
in our name help protect you from you
yes
and then we're gonna we're gonna decide
together what's good for you for your
future we don't want your money but
would you like us to control it to
protect you from you so that you can get
the best use of this going forward in
your life and we'd be willing to take
that role but you have to volunteer it
to us we're not going to force it on you
oh that's a great idea it might be worth
painting a picture of what he felt like
when he was 16 and had no money in the
bank
and was somewhat on his own without
somebody who cared for him like you do
and say hey you're about four months
away from that picture being true again
let's don't do that
yeah you don't want to be you don't want
to be aging out and broke
exactly yeah I really like that idea
thank you so much but um but again then
it's incumbent upon you
to uh what what legal Scholars would
call AF be a fiduciary meaning you are
doing nothing with this money except
what is really his best interest and
that might even include something you
don't totally like but it's for his best
interest
and at some point it may even be that
you just turn the money over to him and
go I can't do this anymore
because if he's continually trying to
get you to do negative things and you
know is all you are is just becoming a
bad guy at that point you don't want to
stay in that seat either
exactly so this doesn't have to be
forever and it doesn't have to be for
long but you know you told me this is
stupid stuff would you and I like to
would you like to put together a plan
with me where we don't do stupid stuff
because I'm really worried about you
aging out of the system and not having a
plan and not having this money to do
something with and I really want to help
you do that and move you towards some
kind of I don't know post high school
education ideas you know to getting a
certification on coding over at the code
school or going learning get a heating
and air certification learn how to be a
tech or whatever it is she's going to do
with his life or maybe he's going to go
to college I don't know but uh whatever
it is I mean this money can move there's
a little bit of it left and it by the
way it was a scholarship for Education
not for models and food another really
valuable tool that a parent can use is
really what Dave and I do and all our my
personality colleagues do which is
provide a picture from our own life so
there may be a moment when you needed
somebody to step in and help you or you
had to put some hurdles in front of you
you between you and a behavior man
that'd be a great moment to
be vulnerable and say hey this has
happened to me it's like I've said on
this show there was a season when I gave
my debit card to my wife because I I
simply did not control my spending so I
needed to start from from Ground Zero I
just gave it away I took my ability to
do that away and it's a story like that
that you can share with him about your
own life that may provide him a path of
an empathetic path back to you
relationally maybe that Dave I love that
idea
um and I wouldn't have thought of that
but that's really wise you're in the
influencer role you are not in the you
do what I say role you can play that
game and you got about six months on it
he turns 18 you will never see that kid
again yeah yeah it's a persuasion let's
let's create a vision for your life yeah
I love you whether there's no vision the
people perish
Kim you're a hero thanks for stepping in
for a kid in the last stages of the
Foster system man that's a big big deal
right there you're amazing thank you
thank you thank you for doing that this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
yeah
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today he does a show called The
Dr John deloney show that is a very
popular Ramsay networks podcast and you
should tune into it it's all about
relationships and boundaries and uh Dr
John has a PHD in higher education and
also a PhD in counseling and so anytime
those two intersect we really get into a
great discussion and he sent me an
article this morning and said let's talk
about this here on the air so a hat tip
to the guys at marginal Revolution I
love those guys
um so it's a paper from the National
Bureau of economic research
dinerstein and yanelis and Chin here's
here's the study so most people don't
know this but when it comes to student
loans there's
we'll distill it down but there's two
different paths a college
this is a white paper a white paper this
is not an article on Yahoo finance yeah
this is a research paper this is
actually a research paper by a nerd by
Egghead several several of my of my
nerds several of your nerd friends yes
okay
um so
there's two separate paths one of the
paths is the government makes the loans
and the others the bank makes the loans
and the government guarantees them for
the average borrower you're never going
to know which which one of these paths
your college took but when Biden I think
it was Biden maybe been Trump did the
first
um pause on student loan repayment
it instantly created a pretty cool uh
study that could be done because you had
a group of people Biden couldn't pause
the bank loans because he didn't have
the authority because it was the banks
that made the loans but he could pause
the
loans that the government made and so
these researchers came in and said what
was the what was what actually happened
there
and Dave I I use I was sending emails to
Dave this morning as I was going through
the math on this thing
at the end of the day they found that
the payment pause
helped for about 30 seconds
and the people who had to keep making
their loan payments did not have any
increase in defaults
they didn't have any increase in their
life falling apart the word I kept
coming to was are the words that kept
coming to us they figured it out
conversely those that were a beneficiary
of the pause
ended with more debt than they started
with
and I I just can't have to keep reading
that and reading that in a reading map
because Dave I remember uh Twitter tried
to set you on fire when you said that
thirteen thirteen hundred dollars isn't
going to change your life it's not or
600 isn't going to change your life and
what they're saying is actually that
pause made it worse
people took the money that was uh in
cash that they weren't sending student
loans and they went and put it on down
payments for more debt
so it would look like a great political
move it helped for a few months and then
it got bad so everyone's life is going
to fall apart because of covid and you
cannot afford to pay your student loans
so we the government are here to help
you we're going to put your student
loans on pause the net result is that
people took that pause and used it to go
further into debt
proving that they were not in much
trouble to start with
or that they had the capacity now to get
in even more trouble exactly exactly
compare here's the note from the actual
white paper comparing borrowers whose
loans were frozen with borrowers whose
loans were not frozen due to differences
in whether the government owned the
loans we show that borrowers use the new
liquidity to increase borrowing on
credit cards mortgages and auto loans
rather than to avoid delinquencies so
the narrative was we are here to help
you poor people who have had your lives
destroyed by covid and you're not going
to have to make your payments because we
know you're starving to death and
everyone said hold my beer I'm going to
go buy a car sweet now you get a car
sweet now I can get a car here here
that's exactly what the net result of
this is here's the line by the end of
the sample period student debt borrowers
have about five percent more household
debt
than the ones that did not get the
government help of the pause perhaps
paradoxically temporary student debt
relief leads to higher overall household
debt levels and larger future debt
burdens this is good news for debt
pauses as stimulus payments but bad news
if you think that debt pauses are just
the nudge people need to get their
financial house in order none of them
did statistically wow they went further
in the hole so once again your
government interferes in the economy and
once again they screwed it up well I
think this is a good moment for me to
say I was wrong because I remember when
when you said it's not going to help
save your life and I thought to myself I
think it will I think it'll make a huge
difference
and Dave in front of a glad you kept
that to yourself I I did I did I would
have made fun of you I was a new
employee here
but I think it's fair to say I was wrong
man well I mean the the point didn't
work the point is not a philosophical
uh let them eat cake statement when you
say thirteen hundred dollars doesn't
change your life but really I mean if
you are at the poverty level fifteen
thousand dollars a year thirteen hundred
dollars is not even ten percent of your
income
so mathematically the arithmetic says
thirteen hundred dollars if it changes
your life you really have already a
major screwed up life long before covid
came along yeah and it doesn't fix it
yeah you got some pretty different
infections it is uh one more time the
government's saying they are doing
something and that was a different thing
that was abiding bucks for the 1300 that
set they set Dave Ramsey's on fire all
over Effigies all over us Reddit and
everywhere else and poor you know Dave
Ramsey is just one of those people that
doesn't have any compassion and you know
whatever oh crap it's just an obvious
it's just an obvious it's an observation
of the obviously not a college professor
they told me one time he said Mr Ramsey
you have a firm grasp on the obvious
little did he know I was going to make a
living doing that but yeah yeah so there
you go I do it a firm aggressive The
Meta I took away from this nerd paper
and this this just for y'all listening
these kind of nerd papers make my heart
beat a little bit faster I love them
um
I think this lesson is applicable to my
marriage it's applicable to raising kids
it's applicable to being a good neighbor
it's applicable to my finances there is
no such thing as I'll deal with it later
that doesn't exist it's a false premise
that I can kick a can down a road on any
issue in my life
um
like man pain deferred as pain Amplified
man and the more we kick stuff down the
road the bigger mess we are making and I
think it's an ethical issue when we are
a knowingly put putting hurting people
into more pain down the road or B we are
making our grandkids that we've never
met yet have to deal with this chaos man
it's just it's just unethical it's evil
debt ceiling race it's even here we go
again you know we're gonna do it again
let's just go further in depth because
uh none of those people voting on it are
ever going to pay any of it because
they're going to be dead zero they're
gonna be dead most of them are almost
dead now they're so old but yeah
unbelievable but yeah the uh it's crazy
so yeah that it is unethical and the
thing though Dr uh
Les perrett our friend you know he we've
spoken with him a bunch of times he's
used he's been on Smart conference a
bunch of times and he always says you
know these negative emotions these
negative situations whatever they are
whether they're mathematical whether
they're relational whether it's a career
decision you kick the can down the road
this stuff has his famous phrase is it
has a high rate of Resurrection it will
be back it will I will be back yeah I'm
coming back and so you know don't let
the sun go down on your anger sit down
with your spouse and get this
straightened out it will be back you
can't sweep it on the rug it's not going
to go away it just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger that's that splinter
if you don't pull it will fester and
gangrene will sit in we'll have to
amputate your whole arm because you
wouldn't pull this one little sliver of
wood out of your finger or you know
something scary your job is taken away
from you overnight
tomorrow morning at 6 a.m you got to be
on the phone find something else to do
you got to be on that computer to find
another work you got to figure it out
and I hate saying that because it sounds
so callous but it's me trying to tell
you I love you and I think you can
figure it out well step straight into
the difficult thing go run into the
storm hard things yes Michael Easter
Comfort crisis do hard things step
straight into them it changes your brain
chemistry yeah what Michael would say
which I think is so true is if you do
hard things on the regular as a part of
your life if you're constantly not
running away from a conversation you'd
have with your wife but you're leaning
into it if you're constantly stepping
into challenging moments with your kids
constantly like doing things like
exercising and not going for that extra
dessert when something like this hits
your brain and body are ready to run
into the storm you've tried you've been
training them right when you just take
the stairs right you're training your
body and your mind over time so that
when hard things hit bring it on let's
go do this you know it's exactly right
but if you've been avoiding everything
else and you get the opportunity to
avoid this
I'll kick this can down the road see
those of you that are kicking your
student loan can down the road right now
and you're not dealing with it we're
talking to you it is coming for you this
is not good for you it's not good for
you we've been saying this a you owe the
money and B it's not going away until
you pay it this is the Ramsay show
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're out running
around America and you happen to be
coming through Nashville we're in
Franklin just south of Nashville our
Visitor Center is a huge Lobby
and our radio show a YouTube Show
podcast thing that we do whatever we
call this uh TBN show is on the glass
and we do the show live every Monday
through Friday from one to four Central
Time the cookies are homemade
the coffee is amazing and it's all
completely free come visit us and drop
by and watch the show anytime you'd like
we'd love to have you one of the
features in the lobby is the debt free
stage where people come from All Over
America to tell us their story and do
their debt free scream Kevin is on the
debt free stage Hey Kevin what's up
I'm doing great Dave how are you better
than I deserve man where do you live I
live in Spencer Indiana which is near uh
about an hour South of Indianapolis okay
we'll call it Indy all right cool well
good to have you you're one of the last
guys left wearing cargo shorts yeah I'm
I'm proud my wife took all mine away so
hang on to those things man
congratulations thank you welcome so how
much debt have you paid off I've paid
off 85 000 all right good for you and uh
how long did this take you about 34
months from the time I took on the
mortgage good for oh it's a mortgage
yeah whoa all right so you paid off your
house yes you're 100 debt free yep
looking at weird people oh man I'm 26.
way to go paid off house at 26. yes
what's the house worth uh it's worth
about 160 to 180. I love it
congratulations thank you what was your
range of income during that three years
um starting out it was about 25 but it
went up to 50. cool what do you do for a
living
um I'm an elementary school teacher and
I work part-time at Walmart awesome good
for you okay so you're 26 years old you
owe 85 000 on a house that's worth
double that roughly and uh you looked up
and said I'm going to pay this off in 34
months what made you do that well um I
took your class back when I was in high
school I was about 17 years old I want
to shout out Owen Valley high school and
my teacher Mrs Nichols for carrying your
program and teaching it way to go Mrs
Nichols foundation and personal finance
from Ramsey rocks yes way to go I'm
proud of you cool right from when I took
that class I started saving up my money
working at Pizza Hut and uh graduated
college debt free and from then on it
was just saving money to eventually pay
off a house so I could say that it took
34 months but really this has been in
the work since I was about 17 years old
10 years yeah yeah like sort of I mean
you had the knowledge but you really
weren't actioning on it because you
didn't have the house then so yeah man
you understand how weird you are how
wonderful you are yeah you're a teacher
awesome yeah cargo shorts awesome
you own your house outright at 26.
awesome you knew what I knew when I was
20 I didn't know what day it was when I
was 26. oh man yeah way to go so fun so
fun so how much support did you get
cheering you on versus how much people
told you you were nuts well I had a lot
of support from my family my mom and my
dad were always there when I was making
big career choices or money moves and uh
just walking with God daily was an
important part of the whole process so
without him I you know glory to him
because I couldn't have done it without
him amen
so
84 000 what kicked it off for you what'd
you say all right I'm I'm gonna hit the
gas on this thing well by the time that
I actually stumbled upon this house and
it was just a blessing how it how it
landed on my lap
um I already had about 20 grand saved up
because I was saving for a down payment
so really I only had another 65 000 to
go so I was like I I just want to get
this taken care of you know one day when
I have a family and kids I want to be
able to provide for them and have not
have a mortgage be
a problem for me so absolutely well
congratulations thank you all right uh
wow so this I gotta let our education
team know that this is the impact this
having on a Costco student Ten Years
Later they'll be so blown away this is
such good work they're doing absolutely
and
um what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you have a paid
for house at 26 years old
um I think one of the biggest things to
be able to tell yourself is just tell
yourself no uh when you need to because
I I drove a 30 year old car the whole
time I was getting out of debt what kind
of car it was a 1992 Geo Prism oh God
what a piece of crap that's number four
weird keep going man and you know you
want to get a new car but you got to
tell yourself no you got to stick to
your goal and I live with my parents
through college to save money so you
want to move out you know but you got to
tell yourself no not yet and um
when I was in college actually I was at
Indiana University I lost my scholarship
and so that was the hardest no I had to
tell myself was leaving there and I had
to take a year off and I worked and I
went back to school online and got my
degree in elementary I had much cheaper
so I I kind of missed out on the the you
know college experience but I also
missed out on the experience of being in
40 Grand Institute well everybody lists
listening to this send this to your
local Congressman yeah for real because
26 year old Kevin has a thing or two uh
some wisdom about how the world works
yeah
pretty much golly you're incredible well
done incredible well done sir hey and
let me tell you I I got a seven-year-old
little girl she's a first grader going
to second grade
I I would just about bend the Earth
sideways before a teacher like you to be
in front of my kid so on behalf of all
of us who have elementary school kids
thank you for being a teacher at
elementary school and thank you for
being the kind of caliber person that I
want in front of my kid right that's
incredible man that's so incredible
thank you beautiful stuff and now when
your principal says you guys are gonna
do and you can go no I'm not I'm not
doing that yeah wait a minute that no
I'm not I don't do that I don't have any
pills so I'm just gonna go back to my
classroom and teach my kids because I
love them absolutely that's incredible
very cool very well done good job Kevin
Hey we've got the baby steps
millionaires book for you The Total
Money Makeover book and a financial
peace uh University membership as well
that's the live and give box so uh live
some of it if you want to live some of
it give some of it if you want to give
some of it it's all there for you to say
thank you for coming down here to do
your debt free scream and to say
congratulations I gotta tell you we're
proud of you man awesome well done very
very well done good stuff very cool all
right it's Kevin from Indianapolis or
just now herself yeah 85 000 paid off
house and everything at 26 years old did
that in 34 months as an elementary ed
student as an elementary ed teacher uh
25 000 to 50 000 income count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one I'm debt free
[Applause]
[Music]
how do we do that I'm also gonna
encourage Kelly to put this this call in
my Show's show notes when people call
and say there's just no good guys left
and there's no good guys making
decisions I know of one
just South of Indianapolis
is making good choices out there on the
market absolutely definitely man you're
pretty eligible cargo shorts are not
you're pretty eligible for your house
hey my wife married me with cargo shorts
you stay strong Kevin stay strong
I love it man that's fun what a hero
jeez that's so fun and here's the thing
okay you guys gotta well style through
back through that story for just a
minute because at some point possibly
all the way back in high school he took
debt off the table didn't it's not a
thing
I lost my scholarship I can't go to
school here I gotta figure it out I
gotta figure it out I drive a piece of
crap car
ah so what I'm gonna drive like no one
else so later I can drive like no one
else because you know what you can do if
you make fifty thousand dollars a year
and you don't have a sink and stinking
payment in the world not even a house
payment
anything you want to do you got nothing
but cash flow and you want to buy a
better car I mean he could buy that car
uh three times a month now
you know is that you know what I'm
saying yeah that mathematically that's
where it's obviously not going to do
that but I mean moving up in car my
point is not a big deal and he's 26 he
got the whole rest of his life to become
very very wealthy outrageously generous
and continue to live out God's will for
him I mean he's obviously walking with
the Lord and saying okay God what do you
want me to do now I have no Masters in
my life but Jesus
borrower is slave to the lender how many
Masters it's an Unstoppable person he's
Unstoppable he's a hero this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
uh you can do the offense get out of
debt you can do the offense invest you
can do the offense but you got to do the
defense too and the defense is
protecting your money and your assets
with good insurance
there are 10 kinds of insurance coverage
that you might need based on what your
life looks like
and we built a tool called the coverage
checkup to show you which types you need
to add drop or adjust
we'll even rank your coverage list by
importance so check it out
ramseysolutions.com checkup it is a free
tool takes about five or ten minutes and
you will know exactly what kind of
coverages you don't need and do need
and what your order of attack is and
even some suggestions all completely
free it's ramseysolutions.com
checkup art is in Pittsburgh hey Art
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave John I'm going to get right to
my question but first I do need to
mention I am wearing cargo shorts right
now yeah baby
good for you we got a club going here
hey if anybody's wearing something wants
to get rid of their cargo shorts send
them to me I would love some new ones uh
yeah you got to get past Sheila but yeah
okay
so I am poised to retire with a lot more
money than I've been expecting to and I
had a whole plan worked out and I need
to I'm feeling intimidated by that and I
want to know what to do with it what
caused the spike
uh my partner and I have been in
business we in the group health
insurance business and uh for about 20
years and then we took on a partner
uh and I hate the word Synergy but
there's a Synergy and from 2019 when we
did the merge till now we have
quadrupled in size
and what was always a good successful
comfortable business is now a thriving
business it's gotten the attention of
investors
and they're going to buy you out for
retirement
uh yeah yeah so your original plan was
to get how much out of the business and
how much do you get out now
uh my original plan was to retire with
between two and four million which is
you know comfortable
um very comfortable but now it's it's
looking to be um 15 plus
okay
congratulations very cool all right oh
thank you thank you
it is intimidating
um and the pressure is uh I'm driving a
car
that is more powerful than any car I've
ever driven and I'm afraid it's going to
get out from under me
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah and
then I've got kids and grandchildren now
and now I feel more of a responsibility
okay I don't want to squander this yeah
yeah well I don't think you're going to
squander it number one but the the
principles that keep you from
squandering it are still the same as
they were when you had four million
um and let's review those okay number
one you do not invest in anything ever
that you do not understand
so if something sounds fancy pants
and the guy or gal pitching it is really
really smart and you understand about
three quarters of it and you're a little
bit intimidated and kind of think you're
too dumb to be doing this but you think
this is a smart person I'm going to go
ahead that's right when you get ready to
lose your money
gotcha you invest in stuff you
understand
and if if that dumbs down the
Investments so what no big deal
and you you know it's incumbent upon you
to manage a 15 million dollar portfolio
for the good of your family for the good
of the Lord and to manage it you would
have to continually learn more in the
next five years than you know today
about Investments about but you don't
have to become well you don't have to
get a PhD in finance but you need to
probably always be next year you need to
know more than you new this year and the
next year more than you knew that year
and so on so let's all be doing that
that so thing number one is don't put
money in things you don't understand
thing number two is all of your
financial people whether they're estate
planning Insurance
uh investment Brokers real estate all
have to have the heart of a teacher not
the heart of a Salesman
and some of them in every category have
the heart of a Salesman they are
impressed with their own voice they love
the sound of their own voice instead of
teaching you and again that goes back to
number one where you can't put money in
something you don't understand
take your time
go easy and the last principle is I have
met with
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people in 30 years that have a net worth
of you know a million to a billion
and
anybody under 50 million in net worth
they all
are really pretty boring with their
Investments the fans they don't do a
bunch of Fancy Pants stuff they're not
trying to get on the edge of something
they're not trying to get out ahead of
something and so they'd never do stuff
like crypto ever
in that kind of a thing they never do
stuff that is um
edgy or questionable or high risk they
put money in things they understand now
it might be things other people don't
understand like I know one guy who
actually has about six million dollars
of collectible automobiles
and uh normally collectible automobiles
would not be a category I would tell
people to put money in but he is one of
the world's Premier experts in
collectible automobiles so not only is
it a great hobby not only does he
personally love it his knowledge base in
it makes this an excellent thing for him
to invest in because that's his deal you
know what I'm saying but it's pretty
boring he doesn't do a bunch of other
stuff he does that that's about it you
know he and so this idea that you have
to somehow be involved in something
that's way more sophisticated than you
are is a death trap don't fall for it
does that make sense
yeah it makes perfect sense gives me
some ideas actually okay so all right
can I let me ask you this art
um
I don't have 15 million dollars don't
you have close to that
but I grew up with very little and money
in my house was war right it was it was
a scary thing
and then as I moved up and got new jobs
it and was successful in those places
and then as I've I've worked here and
and Dave takes care of us pretty well
I have found myself
looking at quote unquote those people
and realizing oh I'm one of those people
now
and I didn't have a psychology for it
does that ring a bell with you or no
uh yeah it does to a certain extent I
mean I I've been planning I've been
doing the the steps for you know my wife
and I since we've been debt free since
2010. and I've and and she's a professor
and so we're both professionals we've
always made good money and we you know I
was on this trajectory to be you know
that person you know basically when you
talk about the millionaires between you
know I was I was that that person and
now this is hitting so yeah no that does
hit and also she doesn't come from money
neither do I I mean I come from a middle
class upper middle class if you if you
told me it went to 100 million I would
say it changes the dynamic but the
dynamic between 4 million and 15 million
it doesn't change at all not that big a
difference okay just consists in my
brain just do exactly what you were
going to do with a little more money
Dave can you tell
Dave taught me this thing privately
about ratios and that has been that's
been a game changer for me
oh yeah it just it sets you free I mean
you you're going to be able to do some
stuff with generosity
that when you it's going to shock your
emotional system
and you're going to be able to do some
stuff buy a nice whatever
for somebody in your family or for you
or for your wife or whatever go on this
trip that's ridiculous like I know a guy
that just spent 260 000 on a trip wow
you know awesome and I was just kind of
I'm kind of like oh you did what it is a
quarter of a million dollars and he's
like yeah well I mean he's got a hundred
million so
it's not really a thing you know it's
that's the ratios I mean it's a for for
most people him doing that's like buying
a biscuit
ratio wise I mean it's like other people
buying a biscuit you know so if you can
afford to go to Cracker Barrel he can
afford to do that trip and so maybe in
your head you were going to give your
kids your grandkid you can put five
thousand dollars in a fund for their
college
well now that you look at the ratio you
might be able to pay for other college
and put that in a fund right so just the
the numbers get bigger but the ratio
stay the same and that's been that's
been a game changer for me and any
weaknesses that there were in
relationships or in character of
individuals that are uh arm's length uh
kids parents it's gonna it's gonna get
expanded
and people that are crazy with this when
this kind of money comes in contact with
them they get real crazy
people that are generous in this kind of
money comes in contact with them they
get real generous it magnifies all the
stuff in your family so be ready for
that this is the Ramsey Show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
new work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr Sean
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today he is the number one best-selling
book of own your past change your future
and also the host of the Dr John deloney
show on the Ramsey Network's a very
popular podcast we're talking about your
life and your money the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Rebecca is with us in Louisville hi
Rebecca welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave how are you great what's up
um I really really would love your
advice
um my husband I recently just found out
that he committed what you call
Financial infidelity and I I don't know
honestly what to do at this point
okay so you've been lying to you about
money
about what yes because he didn't tell me
that he was spending it okay what did he
spend it on what how much he spent about
two grand on his credit card for like
just stupid stuff like sports equipment
hunting equipment and like golf clubs
okay and it's a big deal because we're
on baby step number two
and we're trying very hard to get out of
debt right now and I we just paid off
his credit card this month and I I just
can't believe that he just did that and
and I never would have found out if I
hadn't gone and checked the Amazon
receipts
do those receipts match up you didn't
notice uh golf clubs in the house
well that was how I found out I came
home from work and I saw a huge box and
I saw that there was golf clubs in the
box and then I was like so it's not
really good at lying
no he's not
and listen when you're saying that we
are working so hard to get out of debt
you're not accurate you are he is not
he is living his best life
a note okay when we stick to the well I
stick to the budget and I we're going
through Financial Peace University we
got married six months ago and that was
when we really found Dave like your book
and Total Money Makeover and I read it
in like a day and he's still halfway
through the book and we watch Financial
abuse university I mean he tries to fast
forward through half of it and I mean
your name unfortunately is now a
crossword in our house and I never meant
for that to happen so I'm sorry Dave can
handle it um let's get let's get beneath
that
there's other things that have happened
in this last six months that are tearing
you up what else
I just feel like
[Music]
I feel like I just feel like the trust
has been broken and I feel like he's
really angry and going through something
and whenever I try to talk to him about
it like he gets angry again and
defensive and uh just usually ends up in
him yelling and huffing and puffing and
I I don't know like I thought I mean
most the time I were really good except
like whenever he just gets mad and I
don't know if it's the shame because all
the debt is from him
I think it's I'm confident there's shame
there but there's something different
and that is
he didn't fully understand how much his
life would change when his world went
from all about whatever he wants
whenever he wants it to building a new
life with somebody else that we are
going to both sacrifice for and this is
called being an adult it's called being
a grown-up it's called having character
he doesn't have that
he's a child trapped in a man's body
they got a credit card they can just buy
whatever he wants
and he can keep his wife happy by
letting her run around with her little
plan
while he goes and buys whatever he wants
yeah I asked him why he did it and he
said because he felt like he deserved it
there you go
that's the child's entitlement
and so the pro the challenge I hear
folks make at this stage
is you want to make it about the money
and I want you to hear me say there are
bigger fractures in the in the
foundation of your marriage
that need to be addressed
I think I can save this 100 I have not a
doubt in my mind no I don't think you
can y'all can I think he can and you can
together yeah y'all can yeah but you
can't you've been trying to fix
everything by yourself so far money
to the counseling couple counseling I've
asked him before in the past and then go
without It Go without him go without him
I'm going to counseling to figure out if
the if this marriage can be saved I wish
you would go with me
but if you won't I'm going anyway
and then your counselor will give you
words and to help you work through the
decisions of whether this makes it or
not
but you cannot by yourself make a
marriage
that that's the definition of a marriage
I want you to remember this on the same
page I want you to remember this on the
same page on anything nothing yeah
behavior is a language
and if you say what Dave said verbatim
I'm going to see if our marriage can be
saved
I hope you'll go I hope you'll go with
me and he goes yeah I'm going golfing
behavior is a language he is telling you
loud and clear what he thinks he's done
that's what that means
no but but go anyway go anyway of course
maybe your counselor can give you some
if you've got a good therapist that has
a backbone that can uh give you language
to begin to draw this draw him into a uh
a bigger and better dream uh of what
this marriage can be or you know draw it
to a close one of the two will happen
because one of those two is going to
happen anyway but all we're trying to do
is give you the tools to do it with some
uh wisdom and before there's a house and
kids and the whole thing sideways and
also let me give you a little bit of
peace
it is other than the sun coming up every
day couples who have been recently
married in the first six months
experience whoa
didn't expect that didn't see that now
they don't experience outright lying all
the time like you are but every couple
goes through six month hiccups like I
didn't think this was going to be like
this I didn't think it was going to feel
like this and so let's let's
um pretend he doesn't have the tools
to I didn't know how to decide how to be
a grown-up and not act like a child
great he needs to go to counseling and
learn some tools
because he doesn't know how yeah
and you can model what that looks like
by going this is childish and selfish
behavior on that part and I'm sorry that
you got dragged in it yeah and sometimes
women do that sometimes men do it at all
ages it's not an age thing it's not a
guy thing it's not a gal thing and I'm
not even positive to be honest with you
that he was lying to you
I think he just did whatever he wanted
to do and it wasn't like he was sneaking
around the golf clubs were put on your
front porch
so this isn't like he had some pattern
of financial infidelity is when you have
a pattern of lying that is a broken
trust and I don't think that the I think
the only trust that he was going to
follow this plan was in your mind
I don't think this guy ever signed up
for the trip you took him on
well I
thought you put on there like well then
he did lie to you on that he broke he
broke it he broke his contract he said
I'm not going to spend any more than x
and I did whatever I wanted to do
because that's all five-year-olds say I
deserved it
way five-year-olds in congressman
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show Dr John deloney is my
co-host today if you're just listening
the show trying to piece together what
we're
what we teach you could do that on your
own it's called Common Sense live on
less than you make you can watch about 9
000 different YouTube things by the way
there's been over a billion
hours of our YouTube show watched that's
kind of crazy
a billion
wow that's just nuts the downloads on
the podcast are now over a billion so
yeah you can piece it together or you
can just do it the easy way
and go through Financial Peace
University
um you're going to spend more than
financial patient University on a pizza
in some places so you need to check this
out and right now Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman George camel Eddie Cullen are
all teaching Financial Peace University
classes and still have openings Rachel
and Jade are teaching them but theirs
are well underway and closed okay if you
want to join mine tonight's it's the
last night we've done two sessions it's
going it's incredible it's a blast oh
cool so join mine uh I want to cross a
certain threshold so if you're on the
fence we got got uh eight lessons left
join us man we're having a blast all
right so you can be in Dr John's class
there you go
fpu.com fpu.com or go to
ramsesolutions.com and when you're
signing up for FPU just uh message us
let us know you want to be in the
personality class Dr John's class if you
wanted to that kind of thing Chris is
with us Chris is in Newport Beach
California hi Chris welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello thank you for having me sure
what's up
uh I was just calling because uh I have
a gambling addiction and I don't know
exactly how to stop it because I've
tried and I'm also worried of like I
because I don't want it to affect my
life obviously anymore
Wow that's scary man yeah tell me about
it yeah
um it started about like two years ago
um I
I noticed it so it was fine at first
because you know I was winning and stuff
and so I didn't think it was a problem
then I noticed when I was losing I was
still doing it and then it kind of got
out of hand in bigger numbers so it
hasn't like ruined my life or anything
yet but I'm kind of afraid that
you know
the way it's going and the way I can't
stop it I don't want it to ruin my life
you know what are you playing yeah
uh uh it's kind of like every the
problem is mostly online because like
you can access anything but yeah Sports
gambling to table games
what scared you recently that made you
pick up the phone and call
did you have a big loss
nah I just I just uh in the situation I
watch your show and in the situation
I've
I am in right now like I I don't have
like any depth or like I'm I'm flying
off right now with the amount of money I
have which is around 130 000 but I don't
I was calling to see if like there's a
way or tips like to maybe stop it
because I don't want it to lose any of
that and also like
you know affect my life poorly how um
how much have you lost yeah
uh probably about 20 000. oh
how honest can I be with you
very honest I don't think you're there
yet
okay because you you want to do this and
have it not affect you
no I want to not do it no no you want
you want to stop gambling
uh but you don't want it to impact your
life
uh and if you want to truly stop an
addictive behavior like gambling
you're gonna have to change everything
you're gonna have to go all in and I
don't hear that yet
I took a call you can google and find it
on my show on the Dr John deloney show
where I sat with somebody for a while
and you can hear in the first 30 seconds
that kid is so done
so let me tell you you cannot absolutely
cannot do this by yourself you can't
Flex through it you can't White Knuckle
it you can't just
um you can't just do somersaults in your
front yard and call it good you're gonna
have to reach out to somebody and say I
need help you're gonna have to submit
yourself to a plan into a group to
people so you need to get a counselor
and you need to get in and you need to
get in Gamblers Anonymous today
and you gotta unplug the Internet it's
going to require yeah some radical
action like you're gonna have to get rid
of your get rid of your phone
you have to unplug your internet you
gamble on desktop or on your phone
uh phone
oh phone okay all right yeah yeah just
get rid of you know take everything off
your phone except uh uh phone and an
email
okay and let me back back up one thing
with some of your smartphone now when
they have a
um when they're doing something that's a
an addictive behavior the way I Define
addiction is it's hurting you and you
keep doing it anyway
I always want to ask what is going on in
your life that this is the way your body
has chosen to get through the day
yeah uh uh I caused my I feel like I do
it I go to it whenever like
bad things happen or things don't go my
way so then that's like my mechanism to
kind of ignore it be more specific
what's a bad thing
uh uh maybe like arguments with my
girlfriend or uh like
whatever I don't know maybe a job I
don't get or something bad happens or I
have to I don't know I feel like I need
to like get a win anytime I get a loss
and any way you could think of I'd try
to get a win as in you know go to
gambling
so let me be super straightforward and
clear with you this will end in complete
catastrophe
yeah do you believe me
no I believe you that's why it's hard to
believe when you when you're young and
smart and you kind of figured it out you
got 130 000 in the bank
this will end with you having nothing
no I know that's why I'm afraid because
I've seen it and I've heard it obviously
so I don't want that to happen so you've
got to go no pun intended All In
on getting well
okay
so
um are you going to contact Gamblers
Anonymous today
uh yeah I can for sure I mean off your
phone today
uh
I'll try nope nope you're not ready
okay
call us when you owe forty thousand
dollars and you've lost all 130 we're
gonna tell you the exact same things and
you're gonna hear it differently
if you're not willing to take stuff off
your phone and you're not willing to
plug into Gamblers Anonymous
strip everything off but messages
texting and email and deleting all of
your all of your contacts and no browser
no browser that you can search and no
apps and no apps just take it off you
don't need a phone you tell me if it's
not the only way have you been able to
fluctuate through it yet
no no
and the problem that your body has
decided is that the only way through it
this discomfort is to do it more
uh and then to do it more and then when
you have your first have you had a big
loss yet twenty thousand
no I'm talking a big
uh I think 2000 was the most okay yeah
you haven't had a big one yet
well I don't want to I know
but you don't want to do the steps I can
I don't think you're going to call are
you gonna call I don't think so yeah
I want you before the day's over to make
a phone call and get connected to a
group and go tomorrow morning skip work
if you have to whatever you got to do
man yeah and clean that phone off as
soon as you get off the air with us yeah
and if you're not gonna do that Chris
you're just saying I'm not ready you're
verifying what John's telling you and um
I want him to be wrong he wants to be
wrong but you got to be ready nobody can
do this for you and here's the thing the
two fastest growing addictions that are
destroying people's lives right now
number one is online porn number two is
online gambling we know that because we
work with people with money problems and
100 of addicts eventually have severe
money problems and you can hear it my
voice
frustrates me man I I'm heartbroken
because I just know where this heads I
know there's leads every time
the 12 steppers say you have to hit that
hit bottom and everybody's got a
different bottom is it a high bottom a
low bottom and sometimes a low bottom is
scorched Earth you've lost everything
your job all your relationships all of
your fiances and your parents won't talk
to you and you have no money that's a
low bottom you're homeless and in the
street sometimes the guy like this
they'll get scared and goes whoa whoa
yeah and he makes the call and that's a
high bottom make the call yeah High
bottom is I lost 20 grand and it woke me
up and here I sit in Gamblers Anonymous
we love you Chris but my story is not as
flamboyant as the ones that had a low
bottom that's okay it's still your story
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt-free stage Paula's
with us hey Paula how are you hey I'm
doing a fantastic thank you so excited
to be here well we're honored to have
you where do you live I live in Oklahoma
City oh very cool welcome to Nashville
thank you and how much debt have you
paid off I paid off sixty three thousand
dollars cool how long did this take two
and a half years good for you and your
range of income during that time uh
started at 35 uh and making about 70 now
cool what do you do for a living I am
the director of uh people and culture
for a Child Care Corporation good good
and what kind of debt was a 63 000. so
it was mainly medical and IRS all right
yep whoa you owed the KGB money yes how
did you owe the IRS so medical and IRS
yes sir so uh what happened two and a
half years ago what was the wake-up call
so
[Music]
so the way wake up call so it's my
journey kind of started I started
listening to you in 2011 my middle son
was at Oral Roberts University and he we
were coming back from in Nashville
actually we I have lots of uh good
friends that live here and he said mommy
you gotta listen to this guy named DJ
Dave he's like DJ Dave he's the guy he
said you gotta listen to him and so he
was like you're gonna love him he talks
about money and I was like okay so we
listen to you on the way back and for so
long you know I was dave-ish like a lot
of people it wasn't it was it didn't
seem like you know any my life wasn't on
fire so you know and most of us don't
really uh get going until you know
something walks down our street you know
what I'm saying so anyway
um so uh that kind of I have been
listening to you for a long long time
and then uh fast forward the 2016
um I was married for about 25 years and
um pastor's wife stay-at-home mom and
ended up uh independently owned and
operated AKA single and so I had gotten
a divorce in 20 2016 and I just didn't
know how to I knew how to pay bills and
spend money but I did not know how to
budget and my son Andrew who he is
fantastic with money he's actually a
financial planner and um by trade and so
he I just told him I said hey Andrew I
said um can you help me you know show me
how to budget and he was and he said
okay well mommy he said I told him I
said this is what I get paid and what do
I do with this this check and what do I
do with this check you know and so he
just walked me through that and um and
you know and it's funny today because us
Gen X people you know we you know we're
you know we you talk a lot about powder
butt syndrome and I agree with that but
you know at this age you also have to be
teachable yeah because if you can we
should be you know if we can be
teachable then you know we can learn
something and my son he told me he was
like you gotta fat in your purse you
know from richest man in Babylon you
know you know he told me how to do that
but he just walked me through those
steps and um and so
um so started you know still a listener
you know mainly for entertainment
purposes because you know we a lot of us
do find you entertaining you know and
but the advice is amazing just you know
it's just like you say guys and Grandma
way of Grandma's way of doing things so
um so in 2017
um my grandson my first grandson was
born and I became a honey and I started
thinking about you know doing all the
things with him with that I did with you
know my other kids and going to Disney
and going to the beach and doing all
those fun things but I couldn't do it
because I didn't have any money so I was
like okay Jackson is one of my wives and
so um so that was you know that's kind
of how I got started and then uh Andrew
and Casper his wife now
um they were sitting on my couch one day
and they were watching um Michael Todd
relationship goals and I know Pastor
Mike is giving away FPU a couple times
you know recently and a couple years ago
but anyway they were watching it and he
was talking about he was it was a
relationship goal series the original
one and he started talking about divorce
people and single people and he was like
how you should go into your next he said
start getting your bag now get your
money now get your money right so when
you do go into another relationship
you'll be ready for you'll be an asset
and you'll bring something to the table
you know with your next so I became my
next why so so Jackson was my first why
I became my next why and then um and
then so I'm so I thought you know 2019
came along I said okay 2020 I'm gonna
start so I started in January right
right and you know and it was I I heard
you I woke up one day in January and I
literally heard your voice Dave say game
on baby game on and I just I was like
okay this is it I heard you know the
voice of Dave you know and so uh so I
started on that journey and just you
know began to uh started shopping at all
these like Rachel said I've never been
to an Aldi's I had never you know done a
lot of you know now that you've paid off
65 000 in debt what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
consistency and Community you cannot do
it by yourself amen I joined the
Facebook group like I said I started
shopping at Aldi's I started watching
the podcast I came to this I did pay the
money and come to the smart uh
conference last uh year when you guys
introduced Jade yeah and so you know but
just that Community you got you know the
Bible says faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the word of God and it just
does not work just for Christians it is
a principle so if you apply that
principle it works in every area of your
life it's like that tapestry that you
talk about how does it feel to be free
it's amazing was it worth it oh my gosh
yes is so worth it will you ever go back
no sir
I'm just I'm just speechless I'm still
stuck at uh the Gen X are being
coachable man that kind of froze there
that's so rare yeah yeah yeah yeah
what'd you say you said connection
community community consistency
coachability
yep and coachability hey let me let me
just high five you for having
it's hard to to go to the to the guy
that used to wipe his butt yes and you
used to powder his behind yes and say
it's humbling to say that was better
than the first one I don't know what to
do right right that's scary right
exactly good on you it was scary it was
scary good on you because most parents
won't do that yeah yeah I had to I mean
you have to somebody if if you know
somebody knows something you don't know
you better find you better befriend them
yeah you know so
um yeah I'm proud of you proud of you
proud of you yeah you're a hero and you
just ruined it for everybody who says
I'm too old it's too late you just
ruined it for him you were quite the
opposite of a victim of a divorce
exactly exactly I think divorce was a
victim of you
yeah took it down yes yes and my pastors
were fantastic Rodney and Shannon Fouts
at North Church in Oklahoma City
um Samson and and hope very uh varges
they lead FPU I never took it because
I'm always on the road for work I'm
usually just home on the weekends and
then of course Pastor Mike and Natalie
Todd they gifted you know the online P
everybody that you know and so I didn't
I never paid for FPU because I didn't
want but when they gave it I sure signed
up and then when they gave it last year
this year I signed up again too so very
good incredible incredible I'm proud of
you yeah very very good thank you hey
we've got the baby steps millionaires
book for you that's the next chapter in
your story The Total Money Makeover book
for you to give away Financial Peace
University membership for you to give
away since you've already got two and uh
yeah we we want you to be able to be
generous and Pay It Forward because lots
of people are going to be inspired by
you I am thank you so much I appreciate
it amazing very very amazing good work
thank you wow what a story all right
Paula from Oklahoma City sixty three
thousand dollars paid off in two and a
half years making 35 to 70. man she
leaned into it count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream watch out
[Applause]
there we go
this is how it's done
thank you Pastor Mike Todd good stuff
very well done very well done that's
gonna get me through the weekend I'm
ready now I'm ready now I'm ready this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
24 33 and 34 a little sleep a little
Slumber a little folding of the hands to
rest and poverty will come upon you like
a robber and want like an armed man
Western Churchill said I never worry
about action but only about inaction
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Dr John deloney
is my co-host today Joel is in Houston
hi Joel welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well I travel about two weeks end of the
month for my job and I was just
wondering what's the best way to kind of
budget for that
I'm sorry oh for meals okay yeah uh I
mean are are your expenses reimbursed or
what
so yeah I do get a per diem
um a daily per diem depends on the
location
is the per diem for uh food and lodging
or food lodging fuel what's it for
just for food only okay yeah and how
much is the per diem
range uh between 59 and above
oh it's different for different towns
yes it follows the I guess the GSA
whatever that is yeah I remember that
yeah absolutely so can you um
eat
on what they provide
uh I do believe so I mean I I uh it's
probably going to be pretty limited uh
in the options but you know I mean if I
have to go cheap I can go fast food if I
want to do like one meal expensive I
could probably do it
[Music]
I'm confused at the question what are
you what are you getting at
so I'm just so I'm in baby step one
right and I'm just trying to figure out
what's the best way that I can save
money while I'm out of town
okay I don't think you're gonna make
money on this per diem
I think you're gonna eat on it the trick
is to not lose money on this per diem
and that would be to so your budget is
no more than your per diem
okay that's your budget so I mean yeah
if you can eat free if you can if you
can eat for free
when you're on the road because you
don't have to pay for the food they are
paying for it then that should give you
extra room in your overall budget
because you're not having to pay for
food on the day on the weeks and days
that you travel and that should give you
extra margin in your budget to be able
to do your other stuff like move through
your debt snowball and so forth yes to
answer the question you were asking I I
um especially in the past when I had a
similar per diem
um but even now I'll go to a grocery
store and get and that's just some of
that's just because I'm a kind of a
health nerd but I'll go to a grocery
store and get certain foods and put them
in my hotel how long you been doing this
how long you been traveling
um It's a combination I work from
[Music]
companies that I come out and do uh like
Risk I'm an information security analyst
how long have you been doing this where
you're on the road
okay and how old are you
I am 31. okay
I've traveled uh with what we do with
events and speaking and book tours and
everything else for 35 years now okay
and
um I'm out uh some number of days almost
every month and what my experience is is
that when you're on the road uh you have
to be very very very very careful about
discipline
because you you will say to yourself I'm
tired I just got off an airplane I don't
feel like screwing with this this hotel
sucks so I deserve dot dot dot and
you'll take
you'll not only spend too much on the
food but you'll eat the wrong kinds of
food at the wrong time of day
right in other words you'll eat two
chocolate cakes at 9 30 at night and
call that okay as a way to uh I might
know somebody did that no I'm kidding I
didn't do it I didn't do two chocolate
cakes but I've been known to eat half a
box of donuts or whatever at the exactly
the wrong time because you're you're
mentally fatigued travel takes it out of
you people that think travel is
glamorous for people who don't do it
there's actually some some research that
says the the more tired you get with
with traveling it it decreases your
ability to make good choices which day
the intentionality is so important the
discipline yeah so you set yourself up
some systems that says I don't eat after
this time of night I don't overspend my
per diem under any circumstances and I'm
uh and I'm gonna watch my caloric intake
because a lot of people over buy and eat
at the wrong time of day and eat the
wrong kinds of things and they not only
over get themselves in a financial
problem they fat when they're traveling
and they don't sleep well right and it
messes up your sleep patterns and
everything else because you're not
sleeping well anyway you're in a stupid
hotel and so uh which is just you know
there's fancy ones and there's not fancy
ones and there's still a stupid hotel
and so that that's the the problem
you're in so that's uh just be careful
with that I've been doing it a long time
and uh I've had this discussion with a
lot of people who are Road Warriors and
it's it's a real you uh you can really
justify it because you're fatigued
yeah and and so just be real careful to
set some systems in place to make sure
you're you're doing your exercise you're
doing something where you're getting out
in the sun you're doing something where
your your your meals are on a reasonable
schedule and
um
and so what I'll do like when I go to a
town now they'll have me booked all day
long doing media doing interviews doing
lunches with advertisers whatever all
this kind of stuff all day long and I
review that uh itinerary before I leave
and if there's not margin in it to where
I eat when I'm supposed to eat at a
reasonable Pace we change the itinerary
because I have to make that margin for
myself or the road will destroy you I
found a strange hack for myself as the
moment I get to any new hotel as I put
my stuff down even if it's 10 minutes
and I go straight to the hotel gym and
there's something about doing something
that just yeah reminds me this isn't a
free-for-all that we're still at work
and works life still counts calories
still counts sleep still counts money
still is real you know it's what happens
in Vegas does not stay in Vegas you will
carry it home on your belt loops that's
exactly you know it's just for real you
got you just it's amazing all right
let's go to Cameron in Dallas hey
Cameron right quick before I run out of
time what's up
hi Dave hi John I just have a question
real quick um I'm 23 me and my husband
are 23 and we're thinking about
purchasing our first home however we
were wondering if we need to build up
our emergency fund a little bit more
first
it needs to be three to six months of
expenses and you need to be debt free
plus your down payment yes we are
complete free we have enough
say dub 10 down for for our first home
and we kind of have a little bit closer
on the three-month side so we're just
wondering if we need to go all the way
up to six months don't have to we don't
require it
um the reason you would would is if if
there's something unstable
that looks like a coming emergency like
you know while the jobs is unstable one
of the jobs is self-employment and it's
not going well one of the jobs is
straight commission and it's not going
well uh something like that if there's a
reason that you think you've got
something you know you TR your car is
barely limping along you're afraid it's
about to go out yeah you may need to
then but I mean if you don't see
something and it's just generally a
vague I like having more money around
thing you don't have to if both of you
have very stable predictable jobs and
the cars are in decent shape you don't
have to
that's why we say three to six months
and so but if both of your you know new
jobs unstable jobs self-employed jobs
um straight commission jobs that kind of
thing then yeah you probably do need the
six month side and that's why we give
that range but the more volatile your
life is the more you would learn lean
towards the six month side for me it was
a sleep tax I called it those extra two
or three months for me just going to six
months just let me be completely at
peace it was it was worth hey I'd rather
wait three months to buy a house and and
let's crank this up then
have that three and think of so it was
just it was it was an investment I made
my and my ability to put my head on the
pillow yeah there's nothing wrong with
that either there's there's but again
you don't need more than that and you
don't need less than that so somewhere
in that range and you're in you're in
the safety zone uh and past that the
difference between the two is a comfort
zone thing so good question
well done John good show today that
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]